bon on va aller en profondeur sur la
stratégie d'hydro-québec avec normand
mousseau directeur de l'institut de
l'énergie trottier et jean-pierre
phinney qui est analyste en régulation
économique de l'énergie au regroupement
des organismes environnementaux en
énergie messieurs bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir alors d'abord monsieur motion
d'abord plafonner les tarifs à 3% pour
éviter comme ça dallas 5 au 6 % parce
qu'on y allait là pratiquement là en
2023 vous en pensez quoi d'abord je
pense qu'on aurait pu retourner à la
régie faire l'évaluation normal qu'on
fait des tarifs sont qu'encore une fois
on a juste un peu de manière
à la pièce les tarifs et ça permet pas
une prévisibilité permettre permet pas
vraiment suivre la vraie valeur des
tarifs monsieur phinney vous en pensez
quoi de cette annonce du gouvernement de
plafonner la hausse à 3%
de sa demande de l'arbitré on avait dit
tout le monde en 2019 lors de la
commission parlementaire sur le projet
de loi tandis que c'était une mauvaise
idée d'allumer les tarifs sur les
l'inflation que sa voix 26
mai en plus qu'est ce qui dit qu'on
n'aurait pas dû plutôt plus auront droit
ça serait de retourner devant la régie
de l'énergie est-ce que entre temps
cette décision de maintenir la loi mais
de la modifier pour plafonner permet
normand mousseau à hydro de garder des
surplus ce qu'on appelle trop pour des
trop-perçus que le gouvernail hydro
devait reverser ces trop-perçus qui ne
sont plus considérés comme des trop
perçus aujourd'hui en effet c'est un
enjeu depuis depuis qu'on a enlevé là la
régie de
centre des tarifs ya plus de trop perçus
comme tels donc ça permet en principe où
c'est hydro québec de faire des
investissements qui auraient pas été
fait par exemple ou au gouvernement de
retirer plus de profits c'est la même
chose on va on va parler de la stratégie
aujourd'hui il suffit nez et monsieur
mouche au mais juste avant d'aller là
une dernière question sur sur les tarifs
compte tenu que le qu'hydro-québec une
stratégie importante à développer avec
une hausse de production est-ce que
met-on si on revenait à la régie de
l'énergie on constate très quand même
que les besoins en coûts de production
augmentent de façon importante et que
les hausses tarifaires seraient
importantes monsieur fille née
ici la régie avec juridiction sur la
production d'énergie mais la régie le
port
s'est pas passé de faire une
planification intégrée des ressources
ainsi
devoir juridiction sur la production
et on peut le voir à fait donc qu'hydro
québec évalue à en simple kilowattheure
les nouveaux approvisionnements
c'est beaucoup plus cher que ce qu'on
voit ailleurs en amérique du nord donc
c'est clair que la structure la façon
dont on fait les appels d'offres le fait
que ça soit pas gérer directement aux
produits directement par hydro québec
production augmente les cool donc alors
la stratégie aujourd'hui qui est
annoncée hydro québec dit je dois
produire plus pour être capable de
répondre à la demande de remplacement
des énergies fossiles d'abord ce constat
cette évaluation qui est faite normand
mousseau qu'est ce que vous pensez
d'évaluation d'hydro-québec je pensais
très bien on est en effet l'on calcule
aussi évalué à peu près à 100
térawattheures le besoin supplémentaire
d'ici 2050 donc ça va après salliot
l'enjeu de la vitesse à laquelle on fait
les investissements et là c'est vraiment
pas clair si on va être atteint pour les
objectifs de cabo intel t 2030 parce
qu'hydro québec malgré le nom des 30
malgré la mention de transition
énergétique fait aucune référence à la
livraison de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre dans son plan
hockey encore ajouter à cela pourquoi il
ya un enjeu au niveau de la vitesse en
fait parce que si on veut réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet serre de 40% de
35% d'ici 2030 il va falloir électrifié
beaucoup il va falloir pouvoir permettre
aux gens qui veulent investir électrifié
d'avoir accès au réseau donc là
présentement hydro-québec 10 pour les
prochaines première année on va surtout
faire de l'efficacité énergétique
or on a vu qu'en général on livre pas
mais kilowattheure attendu avec
l'efficacité énergétique donc on va se
retrouver à freiner la transformation et
hydro-québec au contraire dans son plan
aurait dû dire nous on garantit qu'on
accompagne à 40% de réduction les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 et voici les mesures qu'on va faire
pour électrifier tel secteur tels
secteurs tel secteur donc quand le
gouvernement dit quand hydro québec
pardon dit vouloir doubler son objectif
d'efficacité énergétique à 8 térawatts
heure l'équivalent de la production des
installations de la romaine
c'est beaucoup en fait c'est bien c'est
ce qu'il faudrait mais le problème c'est
qu'on n'a pas réussit historiquement
faire ce don qu'on devrait reconnaître
la réalité investir dans des mesures
d'approvisionnement dès maintenant et
travailler en parallèle à l'efficacité
énergétique monsieur phinney sur
l'efficacité énergétique
je voudrais simplement relaxer un peu
de
retard en moyenne par année sur les
membres
présents pour cent de réduction des
ventes ce qui est beaucoup trop faible
que d'habitude de
[Musique]
le potentiel croire jamais dit
technico-économique d'économie de
l'énergie potentielle
environ
un coin est donc
potentiellement
donc
encore avec la politique énergétique
hydro-québec veut étendre la
tarification variable à toute sa
clientèle
la structure tarifaire sera modifié en
fonction de la consommation va falloir
changer nos habitudes nous a dit
aujourd'hui sophie brochu est ce que
c'est une façon est-ce que ça va une
façon détournée d'augmenter les tarifs
normand mousseau une façon de gérer la
pointe hivernale c'est vraiment dans ce
contexte là qu'on voit cette
tarification
c'est à dire que quand la demande va
être très forte l'hiver on va augmenter
les tarifs prenez les gens réduire leur
demande dans le restant de l'année il
n'y a pas vraiment de raison d'avoir des
tarifs le supérieur à des périodes et
sur l'éolien
hydro prévoit accroître sa capacité de
production de 5000 mégawatts au cours
des prochaines années monsieur fine et
là dessus on fait ça comment est-ce que
c'est la chose à faire
en première main moerenhout rang dit
toujours qu'il faut réduire la banque
produire bien on parlait du potentiel de
technico économique la gestion de la
demande en puissance tout à l'heure son
potentiel en 2030 il est plus depuis le
4 milles de gaoua donc
il faut réduire la voiture pour stopper
l'hémorragie en à faire des transfusions
c'est la même chose
on a une année dont potentiel
et par rapport justement la tarification
dynamique iodé il ya des dynamiques
comme le crédit en point critique et le
réflexe d autres projets par contre si
on met tout dans les mains de l'îlot
mais le savoir avoir une pression à la
hausse sur les tarifs grâce à quoi bon
ces consignes bayrou s'est négocié un
très juteux contrat avec sa propre
filiale de gré à gré et lille au vent la
puissance à un puits qui est pas mal
plus cher est ce qu'on peut avoir avec
la tarification ok
c'est confidentiel
quand même vous en avez dit un peu
normand mousseau en fait moi je pense
qu'il faut absolument construire dès
maintenant le problème c'est qu'avec l'
approche on a privatisé la construction
d'éoliennes on paye beaucoup trop cher
au québec nos tarifs d'électricité
éolienne donc il faudrait que ce soit
fait par hydro québec production on
aurait des tarifs plus intéressants
mieux situé et il faut aller de l'avant
parce qu'on peut pas compter il faut
faire de l'efficacité énergétique mais
il faut aussi comprendre que la demande
en écrivant demande augmenter et il
faudrait et ça c'est pas dans le plan
stratégique absolument qu'hydro aligne
ses objectifs sectoriels avec les
objectifs du québec sinon c'est l'échec
garanti pour 2030 ps que hydro doit
continuer avec cette stratégie d'appuyer
financièrement énergie pour que les
clients passent à la bi énergie parce
que ça aussi ça va se traduire par des
hausses tarifaires dès 2025 normand
mousseau et encore une fois c'est
complètement incompatible avec les
objectifs climatiques donc le problème
c'est qu'on garde les gens dans le gaz
naturel ont fait faire des
investissements dans gaz naturel ont
défini on soutient le réseau plutôt que
de sortir le gaz naturel du chauffage
qui est essentiel pour atteindre nos
objectifs climatiques monsieur phinney
le tue
l'entente entre hydro québec et énergie
re compromis est carrément l'atteinte de
la carboneutralité en 2050 un nouveau
verrou i dans le gaz
ça va complètement à l'encontre du
principe du pollueur payeur c'est le
produit en payer et donc ces
chinois baic soit on compense pas les
pétrolières à chaque fois on fait une
recharge de véhicules électriques non
plus écologique
merci de votre analyse c'est très
intéressant merci d'avoir regardé ça
pour nous c'est un plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit